[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
bachelor party
let's do it
we got some
we got some surprise guests coming today
oh my God here we go wow how much did
you pay for that [ __ ] this guy's
gorgeous
oh yeah it's a one-man party in here
[Applause]
[Music]
can you use the lube for cunnilingus is
it flavor so
I got you flavor it goes right to food
foreign
November 7th and we had an all-time
podcast episode dropped last night
seriously an instant classic out of we
might be drunk just listen to some of
the guests that appear on episode one
alone you obviously have Mark Norman Sam
Morel but then they had Sean Patton Joe
DeRosa davital shangilis Rudy the
stripper and more all in just part one
of this two-part bachelor party themed
episode in honor of Mark Norman's
wedding welcome back to the joke World
comedy update every single Monday
bringing you all the common news that
you need to know from your favorite
comedians your favorite podcasts
anything happening in the comedy world
all on one YouTube channel so if you'd
like to join the fastest growing group
of Comedy fans in the world and
definitely on the internet please
consider subscribing to joke world right
now turning on the post notifications so
you don't miss any videos and
downloading this episode on Spotify or
apple wherever you listen to podcasts to
support the show bachelor party
let's do it what the hell we got some
we got some surprise guests coming today
[Laughter]
[ __ ] me it's Kevin Hart's bachelor
party and we might be drunk this week we
did a video on this channel covering
Mark Norman's actual bachelor party he
had down in Florida in August but this
podcast version of the bachelor party
with all these New York comedians it's
really the gift that keeps on giving for
all of us comedy fans
did you sit here and I'll sit there oh
no that's the David tellsy ah nothing
says you're late then balloons on the
floor
what did I miss a countdown
[Laughter]
to you guys honestly buddy I love the
location Midtown right in the uh finger
on the pulse
[Laughter]
how are you yeah you're here man you
know we got you a nice coffee uh hey
well thanks yeah you know um
there's no better way than to leave it
out
awesome you know I was invited so turn
it up a notch
I saw you last night did you know about
this or yeah well Sam and I have been
talking okay behind your back but I know
that's your style but
um
Samurai wasn't able to make it to the
actual bachelor party down in Tampa so
he set this whole thing up as a surprise
to Mark which is a really cool gesture
from a friend but apparently it was Loki
ruined by Shane Gillis right beforehand
Shane accidentally texted Mark some
details about it asking what was going
on so that's funny to give a little
background I want to do I was mad I
couldn't be at Norman's bachelor party
at a wedding in La so I want to do a
special podcast bachelor party and Shane
Gillis blows the [ __ ] surprise today
I think we covered it up enough yeah but
I wake up to Gillis texting me and
Norman I I had told it was a surprise
you forgot
and then he's texting me dude I'm so
sorry I was like it's all right so
hopefully he still shows up the episode
definitely lives up to all the hype
David tell was tremendous on it it's
always cool to see him on a podcast and
Shane Gillis got there right before the
end of part one which lasted almost two
hours long they didn't tell us exactly
when part two is supposed to come out
but I'd assume Shane will be on the
remainder of that episode so we'll let
you know when that comes out right here
on Joe World congratulations to Mark
Norman for getting married go check out
the we might be drunk bachelor party
episode
he's going to be a hilarious
I'll be in a duplex cross town in about
an hour and a half Bert Chrysler turned
50 years old on Thursday which is very
exciting to any fans of two bears one
cave because of the long-running
birthday gift tradition between Tom and
Bert for those of you that don't know
basically every year for their birthdays
Tom and Bert agreed to get each other a
gift with the Only Rule being each year
the price of the gift must keep
increasing so that way the gifts just
keep getting more and more insane like
last year Bert bought Tom a race car
before that he got jet skis it's insane
this year they decided to scale back the
spending a little bit and focus more on
the gifts value we were doing this
escalating thing where we were just
spending more money and it became
unrelatable especially to all the
[ __ ] poor people that watch so we
decided it was really fun to share with
other podcasters yeah like like when
like when you do a podcast and you would
and and it was like a guy you know for a
while and then you know like sometimes
so sometimes there's like a pecking
order in a comedy word like guys have
been shitty for you for a long time yeah
and then and they've been bigger than
you and then one day you're bigger than
them I wish I could say the real name
I'll say it but edit it out okay
like they they just popped at a younger
age and then and then for whatever
reason everyone has a stall and it goes
back yeah I've been there but uh to hear
them go like they've been shitty to me
when I was nobody yeah and then they're
like so you and Tom do like birthday
presents and I was like yeah I bought
him a race car last year and they're
like huh and then to watch it in their
eyes it was the most irresponsible thing
I've ever done like we mentioned before
the gift exchange last left off with
Bert getting Tom a race car so literally
anything was on the table this year as
far as gifts goes a lot of pressure on
time to think of something funny and
expensive and meaningful to Bert and
damn did he deliver this is
for real
I'm not kidding you
go ahead and I'll tell you the story
once you take the top off is it going to
bite me no
okay
that teacup set was at the house
walkenfeld on the Ober Salzburg and in
1936 Gertie Troost whose husband was
Hitler's architect was she was his
interior designer she she had that
teacup set at her apartment in
reichenhall and a man named Isaac Han
was gifted it he sold it to an unknown
collector who later sold it to a man
named Richard Michael colicker who sold
it once more to the unnamed party and we
acquired it and there is basically a 99
probability that you're holding
something that the Fjord drank from
at his vacation home
this is Hitler's cup that was Hitler's
cup yeah
put it to your lips put it to your lips
[Music]
[Laughter]
that cool
happy birthday
[Laughter]
it was twenty two thousand dollars
[Laughter]
I mean just getting Bert Hitler's teacup
as a joke is a hilarious thought but the
fact that Tom actually went through all
these loopholes tracked this thing down
bought it and gave it to Bert live on
the show is beyond funny to me absolute
home run for Tom and I can't wait to see
what Bert comes up with in April all
right turn around
okay so this this is
your second gift are you ready yeah
[Laughter]
oh oh it looks like Han Solo
if you got bloated in the freezing
process
oh that is [ __ ] great I used uh I
tried to go for the image it's kind of
hard to read on camera but it's the
image from the current tour yeah yeah
yeah you said that the other day you go
that's a great look yeah yeah oh that's
[ __ ] awesome I asked myself what are
birds favorite things
I thought Nazi memorabilia
and images of himself
you know me so well
Dave Chappelle is set to host Saturday
Night Live this weekend for the first
time in over two years it seems like SNL
likes to use him around election time
for some reason the first time he hosted
was in 2016 then again in 2020 and then
this Saturday will be four days after
the midterm elections I'm not really
sure why Dave Chappelle is the election
guy I'm also not really sure the last
time I tuned in to SNL but I like Dave
Chappelle and this seemed like comedy
news so there you go guest spots from
last week your mom's house had on Kevin
Nealon and Daniel Ricardo two bears one
cave was Burt and Tom Tom and Bert
flagrant had on Marquis Brownlee kill
Tony tonight is another episode from
skank Fest featuring Big Jay oakerson
Louis J Gomez and Dave Smith Shane
Gillis was a guest on the Adam Friedland
show and whiskey Ginger had on Ari
shaffir the special is on YouTube now I
saw by the way I saw it I came I watched
you do it live you were there I was in
New York on accident and then
and then you and then a few other people
were like Steve you can stop by and we
were able to make it by and to watch it
and what is what a spectacle I'm not
kidding I was like it's hard to be proud
of your friends because that's such a
lame word yeah but I was like super
stoked and we were up in the in the
corner balcony and we're kind of hiding
and no one really knew that we were
there which was kind of dope that's cool
we got to tuck away and watch you I
don't know man it was so [ __ ] cool to
see that it's cooler to know that you're
because I don't know if you knew I was
gonna come no and I was like should I
text him and tell him I'm gonna make it
or not but then I was like no [ __ ] that
I'll just no it's just nice to see you I
was like all right that's way cooler to
like uh sneak in watch your buddy do his
thing and then go say hi in the basement
people don't understand because specials
are so you know it's a comment but they
happen a lot more now yeah it's the
biggest moment in in a in a between a
one for those or two year to five year
period of a comic's whole life totally
yeah the recording of one that putting
it out but really just the making is
like you that's the culmination so it's
like we get it it was almost like after
someone get past the comedy store yeah
some nothing thing like you get 15 bucks
now but we're all like we did it yeah we
conquer the world this past weekend and
Theo Von talked with Bubba Sparks Franco
Quinones was on tigerbelly The Joe Rogan
Experience was the entire sober October
crew we might be drunk with the bachelor
party episode and Bobby Kelly was on the
Tim Dillon show as far as new stand-up
specials out right now I'm sure you've
heard of it but Ari shaffir Jew is
absolutely crushing it on YouTube this
week you can find it on his Channel for
free we're gonna do a fan reaction video
to this one later this week sometime but
very positive reviews out of Ari's new
special two more brand new specials are
out on YouTube right now you have Phil
Hanley Ooh La La and ran Barnacle for
for the room a new half hour special
that is definitely worth the watch that
does it for this week's joke World
comedy update as always thank you so
much for watching and we'll be back
again next Monday with some more comedy
news but in the meantime we'll be
posting some more great comedy related
content on this channel on our second
Channel clip World on our Instagram
which if you follow us on Instagram and
then DM us we'll send you some free joke
World stickers in the mail on our Tick
Tock just get as involved with the joke
World universe as possible go follow us
on all that stuff like a bunch comment
for the algorithm you know what to do if
you like this YouTube channel you know
how to support it and if you don't like
it you're probably not watching right
now so thank you guys for liking the
channel
seriously though it really does mean a
lot that you guys watch this channel I
mean I I could thank you for hours so
I'm just gonna end this video because I
always ramble at the end of these but I
just want to keep saying thank you I
mean it's it's just so
it's [ __ ] cool all right bye
[Music]